those fires in europe in some places the
worst in decades and they're happening
in multiple countries across thousands
of miles raymie inocencio has that part
of the story
ten rare wildfires burned and billowed
across london yes the british capital as
the london fire brigade stretched thin
and stressed out saw its busiest days
since world war ii the same day the
country shattered the record for its
hottest day in known history the uk has
today recorded its highest ever
temperature
40.3 degrees celsius that's over 104
degrees fahrenheit sparking already
parched grasses
dee and cube and her family fled their
burning neighborhood leaving everything
behind where was the last time you think
you even saw anything like this in the
movies never seen it in real life only
on tv
until now if you told me i was in
southern california with wildfires by
the highway bone dry vegetation and
temps hitting 100 degrees i might
believe you but this this is london and
people are shocked this is it right this
is uh the climate change that we've been
promised by scientists can we still call
the united kingdom a cold country
absolutely not
this level of extreme weather is
life-threatening and we really want to
make sure that people are not under any
illusion that this is serious and this
is here to stay for the foreseeable
future
western europe is still battling major
blazes that ignited last week in greece
police ran to doors shouting at
residents to flee just north of athens
french firefighters are in their ninth
straight day battling blazes twice the
size of paris and deaths are still
rising in spain and portugal
and even though the record heat and
those wildfires here in the uk have
thankfully mercifully been snuffed out
the mayor of london has said that the
threat to even more fires is still a
risk to this whole entire city this
whole entire region and he also says
that rain hasn't come down in the past
month and just look at the grass behind
me this is grass it's yellow it's
parched it's dry and the fact that the
city also has so many green spaces are
formerly green spaces really they're all
turning into tinder boxes which are a
threat to homes into buildings gail
raymie in hocencio in london we get the
picture thank you so much